I often debate this with my fellow CEOs
we're going through a similar kind of
issue in the States as we talk about
border adjustments and tariffs and trade
agreements and I would argue that maybe
our economies about growing our
government's ability to govern them
effectively and that we need a broader
reach I think part of what happened here
with the euro and the European Union is
that you didn't have the infrastructure
we have in the United States with a
central bank and a monetary control
system and as a result you didn't have a
governance model that would be able to
sustain it over time and and and so I
think it's an issue that we're going to
have to wrestle with in some way because
our company is global now we pay for
health care and every country in the
world last year and and and so how does
that relate to what our governments
doing to us in the United States or
regulating us in the United States when
were in every other country in the world
but as far as you're concerned there's
no reason why you wouldn't regard the UK
is a less attractive place in which to
do business as a result of brexit all
healthcare is local
what would you say though to people in
the UK I mean like it or not there is a
large body of the population in this
country who are very very hostile to the
involvement of private health care
providers within the NHS particularly
ones from America I mean how would you
set them set their fears aside I would
start by introducing services then
improve the underlying path through
which people achieve their own so we now
know in at least an app now is that
people define their health by what it
prevents them from doing that they would
like to do it's a barrier I'm a spinal
cord injury survivor I never introduced
myself that way I have a problem with my
golf game and playing the piano as a
result of my spinal cord injury and so
if we can understand an individual's
barrier the health they would like to
have or what their health is preventing
them from doing that they love to do
then we have a point of engagement where
we can get them as involved in their
care instead of waiting until they need
to get their care they're there by
fixed or their health fixed what about
the US health care system of the moment
I think earlier this year you said that
Obamacare was in a death spiral yes what
we have to do is get away from this
partisan rhetoric that's going on the
Republicans need to admit that they
can't repeal Obamacare they can't by the
by the processes and procedures of these
Senate and turn around and say to the
other side of the aisle let's build a
bipartisan fix to the ACA and move
forward because it's standing in the way
of tax reform and standing in the way of
infrastructure development which we both
desperately need in the United States